hey guys today it is the 23rd of sep
tember my name is Jess and you're
watching gamespot news a bunch of your
favorite voice actors could be going on
strike in order to resolve contract
disputes between the actors and
publishers the union as a GAF tra is
asking its members to vote on whether or
not to strike over a number of issues
between the parties Game Informer
reports that the union is unhappy that
the original agreement for voice work
negotiated in the 90s is still in place
despite what they are calling radical
changes in what we are required to do on
set and in the recording studio the
union is after a better bonus payment
plan which would let actors get some
royalties out of their more successful
work as well as recording sessions that
last no more than two hours among other
things voice actors including Wil
Wheaton and Jennifer Hale have expressed
their support for the union the next
free EA access game has been revealed so
if you're a subscriber here's what
you'll get for your trouble should you
be dropping five bucks a month or thirty
dollars a year on your EA Access
subscription you will soon be able to
pick up battlefield hardline for free
through the services bowls feature the
news was originally discovered by a
redditor as the game popped up inside
the EA access app on xbox one
battlefield hardline will unlock in
October and it joins the current meaty
liner for free games which include
battlefield 4 dragon age inquisition at
titanfall madden NFL 15 and 25 as well
as fifa 14 and 15 finally it seems we
aren't the only one stick off the
console war Xbox boss Phil Spencer has
come out to say that he finds the whole
thing distasteful we asked Spencer what
he'd like to tackle next having
successfully shifted the focus back to
games for the xbox one he replied I've
said before the one thing that I
probably find a little distasteful in
the discourse around games is the
divisive pneus that people try to build
between platforms it becomes more about
what piece of plastic I own then what
games I'm playing he added my job isn't
really to keep you from buying something
else my job is to make you proud of what
we are
but and to give you an enjoyable
experience with the product we have
that's one hundred percent of what
unfocused on let me know what you think
about Spencer's comments and be sure to
head to game [ __ ] or we've got stories
on Wolfenstein the new order to and
naughty dog talking uncharted without
Nathan Drake that is everything I wanted
to tell you about today but be sure to
join me again same time tomorrow for a
bunch more news